sponsored by step finance your go to d5
portfolio manager once
bitmex the og crypto derivatives
platform and the best place to buy your
bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to another
episode of the leia higher pen show so
this podcast as you know by now is
sponsored by the og crypto derivative
exchange bitmex so some really great
news for them they've actually recently
launched a spot exchange which basically
means you can now easily buy and sell
bitcoin and
many other crypto currencies on that
platform it's actually a brand new
interface super slick super easy it's an
amazing place to buy and sell your
crypto so definitely recommend them also
i want to make sure that we do say thank
you to them because on this show we do
talk about a lot of supposedly
controversial things like freedom
authoritarianism um some things which
people would call conspiracy theories
which are proving to be true um so
without bitmex we wouldn't be able to
provide you such important conversations
so huge thank you to bit mex um and if
you are interested in signing up and you
know buying your crypto through them and
buying a bitcoin through them then i'm
actually gonna leave a link for you in
the description um and all the
information is there so a huge thank you
and a massive shout out to bitmex
so let's kick this off today we're
having a little bit of a different
conversation so i'm very excited to get
it going joining me today is nick battia
the author of layered money nick welcome
to the show
thank you thank you so much for having
me
yeah it's my pleasure um for those that
don't know i've read the book i reread
it this weekend um i really enjoyed it
um it has an amazing
background of the history of money and
sort of how we got to where we are today
um so
massive um i said thank you for coming
on for those that don't know who you are
can you give us just a brief background
about you
sure absolutely i come from the
traditional finance world i used to be
uh in the investment management industry
i was a bond trader i traded treasuries
and other interest rate products and
then moved on to the strategy and
research side of
fixed income
uh before falling down the bitcoin
rabbit hole and starting to write about
topics like lightning lightning network
bitcoin derived interest rates and
bitcoin as a reserve currency so in
about 2019 i decided to
leave behind my traditional career and
go full time as a bitcoin writer and i
wrote layered money during the pandemic
2020 and published it in january of
2021.
why did you decide to leave what
happened at that point
well basically
over the course of 2016 to 2018 as i was
learning about bitcoin and started to
write about bitcoin
i could see the writing on the wall that
the traditional industry as it stood
at that time was not going to last it
wasn't going to last forever and as a
young person i want to
go to where the world is going not where
it is today and
i just saw that bitcoin would be
absolutely at the center of world
finance going forward for the next few
decades and that's really why i decided
to just learn as much as i could about
bitcoin then at a certain point
um
i had written
several articles about lightning network
and bitcoin that had achieved some
popularity in the bitcoin community and
basically i got some encouragement from
people to continue writing about bitcoin
and so i just took the leap of faith
and
left my career behind and started
the teaching and writing phase of my
career
i think that's such a big leap i mean
it's not a big leap when you are so
convinced right but it is a big leap in
terms of leaving something that you that
you just know very well and it's
something that you're comfortable with
um so
you said that you just knew the
traditional system
sort of had an expiry date basically um
what's not gonna last about it
so the
way that money is created today in the
fractional reserve way i believe it's
unsustainable because the dollar itself
has lost its form so
back in the day we're talking about 100
years ago
when the dollar was still convertible to
gold
it had some backing right it had
a sense of an anchor
but today 50 years removed from the gold
standard and also 15 years removed from
the
onshore dollar system being the only
thing that the federal reserve
backs
and i'm referring to in 2007 when the
fed issued a central bank swap line to
the european central bank and the swiss
national bank that basically made the
euro
and the swiss franc
as derivatives of the dollar
in a monetary hierarchy sort of way so
we have really long
lost
any
reality of the dollar it is
it is pervasive and it is
across the world in terms of what people
use their denomination and then all
other all of these other currencies are
derivatives of the dollar so everything
is denominated in this system
but it's so unstable
that i just don't see it lasting in its
current form the way that it is i see
that bitcoin being an impetus for change
we see that the central banks are now
announcing their central bank digital
currencies so their system in the future
will be
derived off of this new
central bank digital currency
uh
mechanism
and the current mechanism
really will be dying out
you mentioned um fractional reserve
banking
and i want to make that really clear for
people who don't know exactly what that
is so can you explain it to us and also
number one why is it bad and then once
you explain that explain why isn't it
illegal
sure so fractional reserve banking is
this idea that the money that you have
in your checking account on deposit is
issued to you by a private bank not by
the government and not by the central
bank
and so how does the bank issue issue
that money to you they lend it into
existence
and that lending process is done based
off of only a fraction
of the total amount of money that they
lend held in reserve
either in the form of
government bonds or reserves held at the
central bank so in that way the amount
of base money in the system
is multiplied
because only a fraction of it needs to
be held in reserve for a bank to issue
money so we have and why is it why is it
bad because then we have more money in
circulation than is actually
reserved or that actually exists at the
base layer
and that can cause
runs on the bank and
financial crises
unfortunately
the
fractional reserve system
is more or less inherent
in human tendency
so why isn't it illegal because people
human beings
accept
fractional reserve issued money as real
money
and they only demand the real money in
crisis
and the time between that happening is
long enough
for
people to accept it really
it's so fascinating because
that
it
shouldn't be i i don't know even if it's
people accept it i feel like it's
because people just don't know and
aren't aware um
because if you're if your money isn't
you know backed by whatever it's
supposedly backed by like let's just say
one to one with gold or something like
that um
then surely it just becomes worthless
i i agree with you that people don't
know that their money is fractionally
reserved today they don't inherently
understand that
uh but
there are times throughout history where
the distinction is made very clear
to people
that a gold coin
and that a piece of paper saying i
promise to pay a gold coin are not the
same thing
and i think that
and
as you know that's a lot of what layered
money is about
where we look at the history of money
and at what point did people start
accepting a piece of paper
in
in lieu of a coin
and how did that
change the way that we do business as a
society
and i believe
that the
benefits
from this
way of
using a layered money system
outweigh the costs and advanced our
society and our economy
forward now
i'm not making a judgment as to at what
point did it go too far
but i do point out that over the course
of
the 1930s to 2007
that the dollar
because of this layered money system and
its complexity
basically the dollar lost its
sanity and its credibility
it doesn't mean the dollar died in 2007
it doesn't even mean the dollar is going
to die in 2027
but what happened in 2007 is that the
dollar
it it made the world understand that the
dollar isn't real anymore it can it
might stay alive for another 50 to 100
years
but that it's just not real anymore
and then we have the rise of bitcoin and
so a lot of bitcoins rise can be
explained by the fact that the dollar
it doesn't have that reality
and so people have to express that view
via something
so real estate prices increase across
the world
commodity prices increase across the
world including gold and then we have
the birth of bitcoin which explodes in
value from zero
to
uh half a trillion to a trillion dollars
so if you want to explain why bitcoin
exists
you can attribute some of it or all of
it to this idea of the dollar losing an
anchor or a reality
during the 2007-9 financial crisis and
honestly the subsequent actions of the
federal reserve and other central banks
since that time
so i'm gonna delve into all of that um
in a minute um because i wanna really
make clear you know what is laid money
and like how bitcoin comes into it and
really also just like what level bitcoin
falls under um but we'll get into all
that i want to actually just get your
take um just on current events um you
know like quantitative tightening um
that's uh about to start so
in your opinion do you think it's too
late given inflation is already here
astronomical levels
and once this
really does kick in what does this mean
for the everyday person right now
sure so uh i would direct
people viewers to
my sub stack publication called the
bitcoin layer people can find it at
thebitcoinlayer.substack.com
i just published a couple hours
ago a piece on quantitative tightening
and quantitative easing and really
trying to explain it for the average
person that isn't necessarily familiar
with the ins and outs of monetary policy
so that's what my publication is about
it's about research analysis and
education about bitcoin and macro things
like this topic so what is qte what is
quantitative tightening
well to answer that we have to answer
what is qe
qe is quantitative easing what is qe
qe is a way for the fed to ease interest
rate policy when rates are already at
zero so we know that the fed brought
rates down to zero in 2008
during the financial crisis
but things weren't
going as much as they wanted them to and
they couldn't they didn't want to uh
lower rates into negative territory so
what did they do instead they bought
bonds
in an effort to try to lower interest
rates in other parts of the economy
uh by pro you know by providing a source
of an extra source of demand
for those bonds
that didn't work so then they bought
more bonds
and actually the second time that they
bought bonds
rates
didn't go down they went up
and why that is really important to
understand why did rates go up during
qe2 and qe3 and qe4
instead of down when the fed was buying
treasuries that buying of treasuries
should send yields lower because when
prices go up yields go down
but it didn't it sent yields higher and
treasury prices lower why because of a
psyche a traitor psyche and when the fed
is printing money or doing qe
it raises confidence so you sell the
risk free asset and you buy risky stuff
and sends yields higher
and so
the fed in 2015
started
raising rates
when they were at zero and then by 2017
they said we're going to start doing qt
lowering the size of the balance sheet
and um
so qt is the opposite of qe
and qe is buying bonds so qt is letting
those bonds mature and not replacing
them
and in that way qt
destroys money because qe
is the creation of money
so with rates at eight percent i mean
sorry inflation at eight percent right
now
the fed is trying to
tighten monetary policy in two ways by
sorry
take your time you're giving us good
information here we need it we need a
smooth we need a smooth voice for us
the fed takes my breath away sometimes
and what they're doing so
the fed is raising rates
so they're tightening policy they're
raising rates but they're also
starting on june 1st today
letting treasuries mature
and that money now is coming out of
circulation the balance sheet is
decreasing and so the source of demand
for those bonds is now gone from the
market
now when they did this in 2017-18
instead of sending yields up it sent
yields lower
because of the confidence thing
without the fed's liquidity
the fed
creates this fear
and then investors purchase treasuries
because they're scared
and so they buy the risk-free asset and
they sell the risky stuff
so
the fed's intent with qe and qt
versus what actually happens empirically
is very interesting to observe it's not
the same
and right now
we can exp expect that the double
tightening higher rates and
qt will um
basically slow inflation and growth
and so
it's not too late we're gonna see
inflation and growth come down we're
seeing it starting already and um
how long will the fed be willing to
tighten and that's the question on
everyone's mind and that's what i've
been writing a lot about at
you know my publication i'm watching the
two-year yield seeing when that is
coming down
materially that might put pressure on
the fed i'm also also watching stops of
course but i'm really watching the fed's
um
reverse repo facility which is this
concept of the excess reserves in the
system right now it's at two trillion
dollars
so the fed will destroy money i promise
you guys the fed will be destroying
money qt will be going on because
there's 2 trillion in excess reserves
when does it stop we don't know but for
now they're going to go for it
the question on my mind is why are we in
such a mess with inflation because we're
taught that those that govern
are supposed to be competent um you know
and just good at their job the experts
know what they're doing
um so
so i often
end up thinking
that it's destruction by design um i
don't think that they're that
incompetent and what's your take
the inflation is
due to many things and i think that it's
it's
fair to attribute the inflation across
a bunch of mismanagement from government
and central banks
it is fair to attribute the inflation
to supply chain disruptions due to
shutdowns
and
you know a lot of the response to the
pandemic okay a lot of the supply chain
disruptions
cause prices to spike across the economy
commodities input prices transport
prices
labor disruption
all of that stuff is causing supply-side
driven inflation
without a doubt and it's actually
probably the primary driver okay
now we also have
four and a half trillion of qe
that was also done during this time
which creates excess reserves in the
system
it creates confidence it creates excess
borrowing
spending and that drives inflation too
so qe also contributes to that and they
go hand in hand
right so
um and and honestly the
immediate response qe
in the height of the pandemic
versus the subsequent
extended qe well into 2021
and it's actually obscene i'll be very
honest with you the immediate response
was okay you you know you have this
shock you have to provide but then
several trillion more of kiwi to follow
was
was
really unnecessary
the evidence is the 2 trillion in excess
reserves parked back at the fed it means
they went two trillion too far or at
least one and a half trillion too far so
a ridiculous amount of qe that they did
okay
um
but attributing of inflation to
exactly the fed or to the governments
that make all the mistakes
would be i think too singular it's
really attributed to all of these things
and it's attributed to in my opinion not
letting the free market adjust because
if the free market would adjust we would
have deflation
be allowed
where companies fail banks fail defaults
happen
and then prices come down
which brings demand out of the woodwork
ready to support the economy again a
natural cycle
that's what i believe
while at the same time acknowledging
that governments
have to respond to voters so they bail
out people companies banks when it's
when it's when it fits their policy when
they see that that can get them
reelected and i'm sympathetic to the
people the individuals that need help
when uh they get fired for example
unemployment insurance and those types
of things government provides you know
fiscal stimulus to those people
and um you know if that contributes a
little bit to inflation at the margin
it's of my opinion that that's okay but
you know we have to also draw the line
to where the free market response is
allowed to happen and
in 2008 and
nine when we didn't let that happen to
all the european and american banks
uh you set us a precedent
and then that precedent it's dangerous
because then
you always have to bail out the banks
you can never let them fail
because it will tear down everything and
that's the moral hazard regime that we
live in today
which
absolutely drives
some
or most of the frustration that drives
bitcoin demand
back again to bitcoin here we are
so moral hazard with bank bailouts
is once again like a big part of
the fundamental demand for bitcoin at
least you know in the first several
years
of his of its existence
um there's a quote in your book which i
absolutely loved and it's really
relevant to obviously what we're talking
about um you said that governments are
unable to resist the temptation to
create free money for themselves so
explain then the problem with this i
know you've touched on it but i do want
to really make clear the problem with
creating that free money
and then also what that means for this a
standard level of skepticism that we
should potentially have when it comes to
government because if they can't resist
creating money for themselves
then ultimately are you saying that they
can't help but be self-serving
yes
governments of course are self-serving
and why can't they resist think about
the olden days now where gold is the
only money gold and silver how do you
get gold and silver you have to mine it
from the earth and once it's above
ground um it's hard to get because
there's not that much of it and then
societies are forming and
gold and silver are used across the
world for
uh commerce and then all of a sudden a
king decides to take the gold coins
suck out the the metal in the middle and
put in steel instead
and wrap it in gold and silver
is that fair
full stop i mean really that's really
all we have to ask is it fair that the
king
put steel in the middle of the gold coin
and pretends that it's gold
is it fair or not and no it's not fair
why because it gives the king an
advantage over everyone else
that's what we're talking about here
that's what bitcoin does
it allows
no one to fill the coin with fake coin
it prevents that forever and everyone
can verify that with their own software
all you need is a laptop or a phone
and so
nothing
that
a king can do can affect bitcoin
that's the juxtaposition here now i take
my research to the next level and try to
explain as well
all the things that are wrong with the
internals of the dollar system and the
mechanisms and honestly the inequity why
is it unfair that they do this
what is what is it about qe
that rings unfair for people
and makes them frustrated with central
banks and the ability for governments to
create free money for themselves why
does that frustrate them
because they watch them do it yeah
you just watch the balance sheet
increase and you can watch the
treasuries be purchased by the fed
and you can follow the
you can follow the money literally that
they
create and what do they end up buying
they end up buying government debt which
the government borrows
to
and it's not even that the politicians
are stealing the money and putting it
into their checking account
but
they borrow
for
their own political goodwill
and then they never have to repay that
money because the fed either purchased
it or they just rolled the treasuries
over for the next generation
and it
it kind of like no one notices right
they get away with it
they get away with it but
the frustration builds the
anti-politicians stances build
and it's all because
of the inequity that people feel when
they see qe
it and and i don't want to pin it all on
qe because it's not just the fed's fault
congress when they borrow and spend and
then they argue both sides about the
debt limit the left is in power the
right says no debt limit the rights in
power the left says no debt limit
increase
everyone is at fault
when it comes when it comes to the
fiscal side
and then the fed is at fault for writing
a blank check to the government
and the fed is at fault for bailing out
the banks and not letting them
see retribution for their bad
fractional reserve creation right it's
the banks that did the bad fractional
reserve that get bailed out because if
they were full reserve they wouldn't
need a bailout they'd be reserved
right
all of that is is in play
and all of that leads to an emotion
that drives bitcoin demand
and um
you know for some reason today leia
you're asking me questions that are
bringing up the political side and the
frustration very political from the from
the from from the populist side it's not
something that i
write a whole lot about but it is it's
it's there it's front and center it's
what was part of my journey as to like
understanding the fed and going down the
monetary rabbit hole it was 2010 qe2
i didn't know about bit i had never even
heard about bitcoin until 2014 and
didn't even read about until 2016. but
in 2010 i was like
what the hell is this qe [ __ ] that like
i mean it's this is this is not fair
i was 22 years you know 22 years old
like a college student like what is what
do you mean you just
what do you mean you just create and
then you buy
that's monetizing the debt and try to
explain to me that it's not monetizing
the debt
and what is monetizing the debt it means
the central bank just creates money to
fund the government
so the fed says we're not monetizing
debt
we buy it from the banks but you issue
the government issued it two weeks ago
so they were lying to me
and
and that and that set me up and really
set me off
down the path of never wanting to let
the fed get away
with whatever they said they were gonna
do
because i would know the math
and you wouldn't be able to lie to me
because i would be able to observe the
mathematics of your balance sheet and
the effects that it has on the market
and markets generally and um
you know it ended up playing into you
know my bitcoin research career
because here we are you know as bitcoin
advocates and fed watchers all at the
same time so it worked out well
the monetization of debt um that you're
talking about this is something which
has always really confused me so
um and also since i'm not american it's
something which has always sort of been
a bit of a question mark but
i guess doesn't even have to be an
american thing i guess it's a global
thing but the relationship between the
central bank and the government has
always been really bizarre to me um
because people always think that the fed
is owned by the state and it's
absolutely not um it's a private
enterprise so
why are they
in bed together
the
the federal reserve is a bank of banks
yes but they also have been issued their
charter
to
furnish the
currency
in the case of the federal reserve
they've been
legislated
by congress
and approved by the executive branch so
two branches of government
instituted this charter
for this bank of banks
to
basically furnish
the currency of the country
so
yes it's a charter
but it was legislated into existence and
why because
um if we look back at history the united
states tried two different central banks
in its early history both had 20-year
charters both expired um
then the united states went went without
a central bank for you know a century
and then they tried it again in 1913 and
that one that version of it has has
lasted
um
and
if it was the people's
will to remove that charter they would
vote politicians that ran on enhanced
central bank platform and so i
i i don't want to minimize
the importance of understanding
how the fed was created and what it is
but i you know it is the people's will
via the legislative and executive branch
to have this central bank
so
i'm not out out here advocating for end
the fed
or keep the fed
we have the fed
and it is nowhere on
either party or the populace's radar
to
move ahead i mean maybe some part of the
right side has end the fed as part of
their platform
but it really hasn't even close to
entered uh something that's on the
national
stage as as to what we would do without
the fed or how we would transition to a
world without the federal reserve i
think that's
it's really out of um
you know any immediate necessity for
analysis it's not in the will of the
people to do it but that that is the
case it's a it's a bank of banks it was
issued a charter in 1913 the charter has
never
truly come into question
and so it also
makes the currency
of the united states the united states
dollar
managed
by the banks
because it's their currency
it's not actually the fed will tell you
that
the
dollar policy is the treasuries
but the quantity and price of the dollar
is up to the fed
so it's really the fed's dollar it's not
the united states government's dollar
it's not the treasury's dollar
and so that's the relationship as i
would describe it today it's not the
clear it's not the
easiest to describe but there there are
distinctions that we should make you
know pretty clear
yeah one of the things um as well which
i thought was really fascinating was um
this idea that
the va the devaluation of money
leads to
government's eventual destruction and
you gave the roman empire as an example
um so how does the cheapening of money
lead to
that destruction um and what does that
mean for the dollar right now
yes so
uh devaluation of currency can lead to
inflation in a direct way
that's what happens when you
coin clip or you you mix silver with
copper or you mix gold with copper and
the coins actually lose you call it the
same thing but you devalue it in that
you remove value from the coin but keep
the name
and
that
that drives inflation because people
want the same amount of gold for their
wheat and so they charge more coins
so the price goes up because the amount
of gold in the coin goes down
that's the direct relationship between
devaluation and inflation
that direct relationship doesn't happen
with qe
the fed creates money digitally buys
treasuries from banks the banks keep
that money in reserve they don't
necessarily lend it out in the system it
doesn't necessarily drive
lending and then higher demand and then
higher prices right you see the first
second third order of effects there as
it works with qe it's actually why the
fed did qe2 and qe3 because qe1 didn't
even work
to get it going
and so
um it's kindle fire but it's not direct
it's not a first order effect
and so
part of what i um you know tried to do
in the book was demonstrate that if
people wanted to go back and
understand
why inflation
can lead to societal collapse you can go
look at the roman empire
and and explore that now i'm not a i'm
not an expert on the collapse of the
roman empire so i have to you know put i
just have to put that out there as there
there was a correlation that i believed
was true when i was doing my research
during the time that there was a
correlation between the collapse of the
roman denarius coin and other roman
coins during the time due to devaluation
and 98 devaluation essentially over the
course of a couple hundred years
and it and it did correlate with the you
know the fall of the roman empire
and so
that is something that we have to take
seriously from
history fast forward till today and then
we see
zimbabwe and
the the hyperinflation there
and we also can use the deutsche mark in
the in the 30s
and resulting in the third reich
nazism
and uh and hitler and so we have some
more modern examples of devaluation
leading to hyperinflation
but back to your question is
hyperinflation there today
and is it a clear and present danger
from the fed's qe
we haven't had hyperinflation in a
dollar-based way we've had an inflation
shock in 2021 and 2022
granted it's far from hyperinflation
no matter what metric you want to use
you know my cost of living is not
200 percent higher
than where it was last year
um
so that is the case but we also
see the fed attempting quantitative
tightening for the second time
in six years
they're trying to
shrink
this money supply they're trying to
destroy money not print money
the simple act of the fed raising rates
and destroying money through qt
is evidence
that they have read their history books
i mean
giving the fed
the slightest bit of credit that maybe
they don't deserve because of their
patterns but i will acknowledge
that qt is an effort to destroy money
you mentioned um yeah i mean we have to
we have to acknowledge that money
printing and money destruction are
opposites of each other and even them
trying to do it and starting it today
is
their attempt to protect the dollar
and so
the more that they do it the more that
they get credit from the market
of doing that and so is the bitcoin
price going from 70 000
to 25 000
over a year you know the last year's
time
is that partially due to the fed
extending its credibility pre-announcing
qt
and signaling for rate hikes potentially
yes it is
potentially yes
you
mentioned um at the beginning of the
show that um
just because of the way the traditional
system is run
it it could it will expire at some point
hence your interest in bitcoin um
however given
you're sort of saying that you know the
fed is doing qt and they are sort of
trying to protect the dollar um
how long do you think the dollar has
left
if you do actually think that it has an
expiration date
um
at least
at least 20 to 50 years
it's it's it's it's so
embedded in the way that everything
works in this world that there's no way
the dollar is going anywhere
and you don't think that could be like a
catalyst
event or anything like that
but what's the alternative is it gold no
is it bitcoin
absolutely not bitcoin is 500 billion
dollars in size
the us dollar
spectrum
is anywhere between
100 and 400 trillion dollars
depending on how you want to
denominate things or value thing or
strike you know
stock indices or all that so we're
talking about bitcoin representing
less than
or about
1
tenth of one percent of the size of the
dollar today
so what is the alternative is it the
chinese renminbi
no is it the euro
god no
so we have to we i mean
it's just what is the alternative there
is no alternative what's the alternative
to the u.s military
what's the alternative to the u.s
geopolitical position
what's the alternative to the u.s
consumer as a source of global demand
we have to factor all these things in
when we think about the longevity of the
dollar
and we also have to factor in
demographics and so the way that the
demographics
are spelled out today
it doesn't
maybe in 50 years we'll have some sort
of
african and southeast asian
denominated world because of
demographics
but
it cannot happen
uh from a secular cyclical point of view
anytime in the next two decades in my
opinion
so so with that in mind um you know
trying to understand whether bitcoin is
or isn't an alternative um
what do you see the use case of bitcoin
then because a lot of bit people say
bitcoin is going to be the world's
reserve currency so from what i
understood you're sort of saying it's a
definite no until potentially i don't
know
50 years from now something like that
so bitcoin can be a world reserve
asset
and it can be a global online currency
and it can rise
dramatically and even exponentially
while the dollar still is the world's
denomination
or
the world reserve currency
so the rise can happen of bitcoin again
because of youth demographics and
going towards one to two billion people
using bitcoin over the next decade
if and when that happens
bitcoin has an online native currency
becomes
the standard
in smaller denominations maybe not for
a you know american company buying a
british company
um they might do it in dollars but
you know um mom and pop transactions
around the world might be you know
completely bitcoin denominated in 10
years
um
and i will point
viewers back to you know a sub stack
post that i wrote for the bitcoin layer
a couple months ago or last month called
bitcoin versus quote unquote the dollar
because it's not really the best
comparison
we should think about bitcoin
versus
equities as something to own bitcoin
versus real estate as something to own
bitcoin versus your your money market
fund
has something to own
but is bitcoin
a denomination
today
for
like the nasdaq to be priced in
no
will it be that in 10 years
no
right all those companies will still be
jurisdiction usa
right issued in the within the dollar
spectrum
they might have prices in bitcoin and
those prices in bitcoin might even be
the lead driver like algorithms with
algorithmic trading you might have
bitcoin priced
apple shares
leading the
dollar priced apple shares because
algorithms link the markets but that
doesn't mean that the price
on the nasdaq will be in bitcoin it it
will still be in dollars so
this
journey that we're on or the next 10 to
20 years of bitcoin becoming part of our
financial society and part of our uh you
know dna
digitally and you know
and emotionally to like the word bitcoin
popping up in
tv and movies and pop culture and all
that kind of stuff it's that's also part
of it right the word dollar has been
part of pop culture forever now the word
bitcoin is in there
so the transition will be
gradual
it will not be
black and white
bitcoin and the dollar will coexist and
they won't even be thought out of
as
necessarily competitors in the way that
they're judged suppose as competitors
today i think that it's it's a basic
comparison but when you really dive
deeper into that comparison we can see
that it's not really the best what's the
best way to compare
bitcoin to gold and to u.s treasuries
using the layered money framework
and comparing bitcoin to
you know london flats for russian
oligarchs
those type of mental exercises
you know need to be
thought of when we're trying to compare
what is bitcoin what does it represent
going forward
um speaking of
like the idea of layered money um this
is what i thought was really interesting
because obviously correct me if i'm
wrong but the first layer of money is
the store of value so gold um and then
everything as you go down the lace
become medium of exchanges whether it's
like bank notes or promises or you know
promises to repay um
so
the interesting thing about bitcoin is
where does that stand in the hierarchy
of money because
it's the store of value it can be the
medium of exchange and then is that for
you what makes it unique to all other
types of assets out there
the
layers of money
refer to
the hierarchy between a few things
number one
the hierarchy of instruments
and the hierarchy of instruments depends
on the hierarchy of balance sheets
and whose balance sheets are they the
financial institutions
so
the layers are really about
who owns what in the financial system
where does it come from
so your checking account comes from a
commercial bank
the commercial bank
has other assets
as its
layer above your money
but gold
is a commodity that comes from the earth
it's not issued by any financial
institution therefore it cannot exist as
a second layer of anything
gold is just is
and not only is gold is but gold is
purchased as the asset
to issue money against by financial
institutions historically speaking
right they they the banks own gold and
they market as an asset and then they
issue gold certificates
as money and in that way gold is the
first layer of money so what is bitcoin
bitcoin is the first layer of money
because
it's not issued by anybody
all you have to do is have a miner
a you know a piece of hardware and you
can generate the coin on your own
and then any exchange like bitmex can
have
bitcoin on their balance sheet as an
asset and then issue bitcoin balances to
their customers
as a second layer form of bitcoin and
it's all about the balance sheet bitmex
asset bitcoin bitmex liability bitcoin
deposit
and in that way bitcoin is
has very little historical precedent
the only thing you can compare it to is
gold
and how insane is that that you've
actually invented something
that you have to go back
basically all of modern history
to try to find a precedent and you can
only find one
precious metal
which is you know god given or earth
given
and so it it really and that
by itself
bent a lot of people's brains including
my own that you've actually created a
first layer money that nobody issues
and it's a system that can keep itself
without an issuer
therefore no counterparty risk no
default risk
and that can serve as the collateral for
an entire financial system in the way
that we saw
a financial system develop between the
13th
and the 20th century based off of gold
again that's what layered money the
first six chapters are about
how we built a financial system based
off of this pristine collateral called
gold we have a new one called bitcoin
which uh sets the stage for you know
miraculous advance in monetary science
but we're in the you know
absolute first stages of it because
people don't even recognize that it's
the collateral
that we've been waiting for they still
think it's like paypal
or
you know some other
second or third layer medium of exchange
when it's really a first layer of money
and happens to do
all those other medium of exchange
functions
so um it makes bitcoin you know once in
a generation innovation
that's uh that's good to know that's
what i was gathering when i was reading
through so i was like okay right i'm
getting this this is making sense um but
what's interesting as well is the term
um fix the money fix the world
um so i think it would be important at
this point to just make clear
how important money is so do you feel
that money is the center of everything
uh yes you know i do and i do think that
if you fix the money
you can fix a lot of the problems in the
world and that is why i am here
i don't advocate for any political
position
because i think this is so much more
important
the money
that's why i focused on the fed i
focused my career on fed study truly
because
i believed that the the money system was
broken
and i wanted to understand it and i
believed that if you
fixed the money
it would do more than voting one way or
the other
and i made that decision as a person in
my early 20s
and i've never looked back you know back
that's like you stopped voting
uh you know
i'll say that um i i don't have any
i don't have any political energy to
give
my energy is in this it's in the
monetary field
uh
that's that's the best way i can answer
your question i don't have i don't
believe that the political energy is
where i should dedicate any of my
effort passion or intellectual capacity
to advocate
for or against political positions i
want to focus on the monetary system
and what is money and what it means i
believe it's broken
and uh you know dedicated
my career to
research and the education on the
monetary front you know exclusively so
you know
my viewers and readers will hold me
accountable that you know i won't dabble
in politics it's not why i'm here
that's so interesting because i um i
always feel although bitcoin is a
political um it it just does have and i
can't help but feel it these underlying
kind of libertarian ideologies in terms
of you know decentralization so there
isn't one authority which can dictate
what has to happen
um
but i i know a lot of people don't sort
of agree on that no i do agree with you
i do agree with you and um you know i
can admit that the political bias that
gets
that people have that makes them
attracted to bitcoin
can have that slant and
it's
it's my slant as well that i just i
believe in that
i believe in that freedom that's part of
you know what i would but
i express it now through bitcoin and i
think that the bitcoin is the political
platform
because i can believe
in bitcoin i don't have to pin
my hopes on a politician or a political
party or even a even a piece of
legislation
um
or
the law in english
language i love math and so
uh bitcoin is is a mathematical
political platform and that's something
that you know can excite
i think um
anybody
i understand um just finally
what do you think about um
the future of decentralization so
you know we had kings and queens
and then power sort of devolved to
governments
um we saw further devolution um right
now personally and we don't really need
to get into this but i sort of feel like
things are becoming more authoritarian
there's more centralization
um and so it feels like sort of going
the other way um but do you think we're
gonna get onto this whether it's a
bitcoin standard or a decentralized
standard whereby you know we see a lot
more um
yeah decentralization of power basically
i think that you'll have the coexistence
again of you know
the dollar bitcoin you'll have the
coexistence of the more totalitarian
side and the more completely
decentralized digital first
um you know
um
passport-free sort of you know mentality
so
watching that
develop over and and and really watching
bitcoin's influence on that
uh going forward it's going to be very
interesting so
i agree with you we're seeing uh you
know a move toward totalitarianism
in many ways at the same time a move
toward decentralization in any in many
ways so um
i think that
the fact that we still have
the growth of bitcoin
despite
everything else going on around the
world
is a positive sign that bitcoin will
continue to
see
its own
light right that we will continue to see
a
future in which bitcoin is a part of
people's lives
that will influence families
family offices countries companies
and to go that direction it'll influence
politics
as well um i don't have any
strong prediction of how that will
develop outside of the united states i'm
hopeful to see
you know from my perspective random i i
don't mean that in any disrespectful way
but random countries coming on to a
bitcoin standard like el salvador and
central african republic they're random
in that they don't have a position in
the global economy but it's not random
that people or leaders from small
countries want to explore a new monetary
reality so yeah
they will randomly appear on our scene
but in those countries it will feel
the na you know like a natural
um evolution
so
i as long as we see that and then you
know from the united states perspective
i completely believe we will see
um
states go full bitcoin
you know i look to tech you know texas
and what they're doing and um
so we'll have jurisdictional arbitrage
all over the world
totally agree with you um jurisdictional
arbitrage is is a great way to put it um
i think we're already starting to see
that anyway um in terms of
um in terms of the pandemic and medicine
mandates and all sorts of things some
are more authoritarian and totalitarian
than others um
yeah so that's pretty interesting just
cross the border
oh yeah just go up north a little bit
that's right
yeah exactly um but nick it's been such
a pleasure i want to thank you so much
for coming on how can people get in
touch with you follow your work how can
they buy your book laid money
absolutely so i appreciate you having me
today leia i had a lot of fun uh great
questions and great interview
everyone can find all my links at
layeredmoney.com
so that's layeredmoney.com links to the
book on amazon audible
people love the audiobook you also have
a link right at the top to my sub stack
uh publication called the bitcoin layer
uh or you can find that directly at the
bitcoinlayer.substance.com
perfect thank you so much nick it's been
such a pleasure and thank you everyone
for watching if you enjoyed this video
please don't forget to hit the like
button and also subscribe so you never
miss a video and you help support the
channel because we have very important
conversations here um and we uh try to
wake people up and bring them to
the better side um there you go so nick
thank you so much
thank you
and also major thank you to the sponsors
bitmex step finance and block fight we
will see you all next week malaya high
open show
you